[Music]
okay welcome everyone thank you very
much for making it the long way here to
the Palace Hotel I know it's like a ten
minutes walk from the Moscone so I
really appreciate you making the way
here that shows dedication so thank you
very much first of all I want to start
off a little bit what am I going to talk
about today because if you see this and
you think like this is not what you
expected please feel free to change
rooms I don't want to keep anybody here
that doesn't get what they expect so
first of all I gonna start with cloud
span architecture recap so I want to get
everybody on the same page what's the
terminology
how does cloud spinner work under the
hood okay second one is the scheme under
cloak optimization so we're going to
talk about common challenges or things
that we see even when developers and
operators work with cloud spanner so I
gotta address those I'm gonna talk about
multi region configurations what they'll
take wait for and what does it mean
behind the scene and then at the end I
also give some recommendation about
related sessions to this one so first of
all a little bit about myself I'm a
developer advocate for the Google cloud
platform I'm concentrating on storage
and database system with like a very
deep passion on cloud spanner so I've
worked through cloud spanner for over a
year now I've done the keynote demo last
year where we demonstrated like the
scale of spanner and today and in this
next 18 we're basically looking at like
manageability of cloud spanner what is a
cloud developer advocate we understand
ourselves to be the bi-directional
interface between developers operators
that build on our platform and the
developers and operators said build the
platform inside Google so please please
please feel free to reach out to me you
find me on Twitter you find me on other
channels if you have challenges if you
have recommendations how to do things
better we have always an open year for
that all right first of all I want to
take a little bit do a pulse check who
is here today
who is a developer here in the room all
right that's awesome that's my audience
who is an operator okay i TDM see CX o
okay we have a couple welcome so that's
very good who is using already
cloudspinner today Oh awesome
awesome okay so half the room is using
it so for you it's basically a refresher
at the beginning and then I hope I can
show you a couple of tricks how to get
the most out of cloud spanner alright so
if you read the statement about cloud
spanner we are a relational database
service that provides strongly
consistent transactions and that scares
horizontally now that sounds pretty
awesome right so if you look at these
things separate you have that around
today like in many many faces if you
look at strongly consistent databases
they're like relational databases out
there for 40 years plus very like
hardened and everything but they don't
have the scalability aspect now if you
take the transactional the consistency
way you have like for 10 plus 15 plus
years the so-called no SQL databases
around that give you the horizontal
scalability but you do have to do
sacrifices on the consistency now cloud
spanner tries to combine these things
and I gotta talk about it how we're
gonna do how we are doing this so let's
start with an architecture recap first
of all about the terminology there are a
couple of things that are like very
familiar to people that work with
relational databases so we have an
instance which basically gives you a
resource pool your nodes that you have
and how many data how much data you can
store in an instance then you can store
I think up to 100 databases in an
instance and in each database you can
slow up to 2048 I believe tables now
these are the constructs that are
visible to everybody outside like if you
use spanner and that's already concept
that you used to work with relational
database now to provide the scalability
in cloud spanner we have another
construct which is hidden from you and
that is called a split so basically what
we are doing all the tables are like
ordered by lexicographically by the
primary key
and then we divide them into chunks that
we call split and that allows us to
scale we can basically hand these chunks
between the resource nodes that we have
available and make them responsible for
different of these splits and by that we
get these the scalability that we see so
if you look at like kind of an
architectural view of a regional
instance you have three zones for a
regional instance and you have your
compute resources and your storage
resources now they are like independent
scalable we have some restrictions how
much how many notes you have to have at
least for a certain amount of data so
per to get her two terabyte you need at
least one node so you cannot school
scale further down and then this
restriction but other than that you can
scale to thousands of nodes even if you
have only a couple of terabytes of data
now in your zones you have basically the
computes for each node that you buy from
us in the cloud console you get this
node three times replicated once in each
zone and then we have the storage which
again is also replicated which is not
illustrated here in this in this graphic
but the storage is also replicated to
like I don't know how many nines of
durability now one thing that we need to
basically organize and have this strong
consistent system is something to
basically synchronize like who is
responsible for a certain part of your
data and we never never never want to
have to compute resources be responsible
for the same amount for the same data
because that is where inconsistencies
come in so we needed some kind of
mechanism to make that make sure that we
never have to owners of a data piece now
one way to do this is with communication
but communication especially if you go
further away from each other so if these
zones are a couple of milliseconds
milliseconds apart from each other
you basically in cura round-trips so if
you look at traditional databases they
ensure like consistency with the
two-phase commit protocol and for the
two-phase commit protocol you need MA
round-trips basically to ensure this
consistency now that is very expensive
and it wouldn't scale obviously so we
needed another way to ensure the
consistency while being able to remove
this additional communication and the
way that we did this is that we in win
in invented true time with the spanner
system so what what is true time here so
now if you look at a true time true time
is basically a system that quantifies
the worst possible error or drift
between clocks all over the world so in
all our data centers we have so so
called GPS Marsters and timer so the
atomic clocks which are synchronized
through GPS and then we can quantify how
much they drift at most and by this we
are able to basically choose so called
so time than this time step interval
where we can say that the lower end of
this interval has passed everywhere and
the upper end of this interval has pair
has passed nowhere so you see there if I
read like the true time now returns an
interval t1 and t2 where t2 is t1 so the
lower bound plus 2 it epsilon which is
basically our security in terms of like
the drift that we expect and then so t1
is guaranteed to be lower than the value
of a global clock at the instance when
now finishes executing so when you get
this interval this has definitely passed
and t2 is guaranteed to be higher than
meant when this throw trying turn now
starts executing so we use this interval
this two time interval to ensure strong
consistency across the database and not
only within one region we can do that
across the regions even so let's look at
a little bit about like how does it work
let's start with a simple life of a
career here so here in this case I want
to do a consistent read so I basically
want to get the latest state of my
database and we choose here a select
statement so I select from event where
the name is next 2018 now the year the
request comes in from your client it
goes to follower because
it's the one that is closest the
follower of the split so you basically
have the paksas crew where you choose a
leader and then you have two followers
and then the leaders basically who holds
holds the whole truths of your data for
that split now the request comes in to
your follower and the follower sends a
request to the leader of this pack so
screw in so it's like hey do I have the
latest data and if the leader sends back
and says yes like this timestamp is what
I have if you have this timestamp you
have to let you have the latest data the
follower surface the data bag so there's
no data going between the leader and
follower here it's really just the check
do I have the latest data now in the
case said the data is not there yet
basically what the leader responds is
saying like hey like that you don't have
the latest data this is the timestamp of
the latest data please wait that out
till you see that times them and once
you see it you can serve the data
because then you know that you have the
latest data all right
we have also another construct in
spanner which we use for optimization
especially if you use a global instance
and you want to have fast response times
you can do something which is called
time boundaries and time boundaries are
not consistent not strong consistent
they are consistent that they are
consistent time bounded reads but they
are not the latest ones basically now
for a time by order three its so-called
stale read you can define a boundary you
can say like okay I accept data which is
up to like let's say 15 seconds old or
you can actually define an instance of
time within one hour so we allow up to
one hour that you can go back in time
with a time bound agreed and then the
time bound read in like many many many
many many many cases especially if you
use a 15 seconds time bound the data is
already there for your follower because
if we have a transaction not as directly
as part of the transaction but
immediately like when the straight
action is happening we are sending out
that data to all the followers so they
have that actually pretty quickly so
here in this case if we do a request and
we say like we allow 15 seconds all data
the follower basically checks
do I have like if the data hasn't rained
for a while we basically send a
heartbeat to update like this is the
latest latest data then we can say like
okay I have the data I don't need to go
to the leader I can directly serve the
data and I leave the leader alone which
is pretty amazing now I want to look
into into rights so I mentioned one
thing is like two-phase commit is
something that is expensive another
thing which is expensive is is locks so
spanner was designed in a way you only
use what you need so if you know if you
don't need certain things we don't you
don't pay the penalty or for instance
the two-phase commit so as an example if
you like go in the traditional database
and you want to have like take you do a
transaction but you only read something
in this trench actually you don't
actually write something you still
acquire locks and you still have like
certain two-phase commit and and some of
the systems and you basically pay the
penalty for that even though you haven't
maybe not even changed any data now in
spanner we allow for certain kind of
transactions to actually be locked less
and we allow for certain kinds of
transaction actually for locks to be
shared so here's an example of a single
split right in a single split right
let's say it's a point update and let's
also say it's a blind update so I'm not
reading anything I just say this value
with key 100 I want to write I want to
write a as you see on the left side I
want to write for keep 100 the value a
so what's happening basically this comes
in let's say through the API fond end
and we do a split and leader lookup now
this is very heavily cached I let it in
left it in here in the graph but
basically that the round-trip that you
see to the sown master is like very
rarely happening because we are caching
very heavily in the front and where the
splits are living and we are the leaders
off of these bits so we basically get
back what the who the split leader is
and so we're sending through the split
leader the commit request and I would
actually change the slide right now
because there's an error
this Zen commit request goes to split
lead or not to the other applicants I
apologize for that mistake now what the
split leader does it basically acquires
a right lock and then assigns it through
time stem waits out at that time while
this waiting out this time we send a
resist request to to the other replicas
as soon as we get a majority of
acknowledge that this persists that this
change was persisted rebase is a okay
quorum is reached we can we just wait
out the true time upper bound we know at
that time its persisted and then we send
back to the front end of the decline
that the transaction was successful now
I mentioned this is a blind read blind
right and in a blind right we can
actually share the right locks so if we
have multiple blind write transactions
they can share the right lock which is
amazing so you can actually just use
true time for the ordering and they are
not like conflicting and we can share
the right locks all right so let's make
that a little bit more complicated now
in this case we have a multi split right
so here what I'm doing is I'm reading
the value from the key 100 I'm writing
awhile you to keep 100 the value eight
I'm writing a key value of two the key
300 the value B and two the key 400 the
value C now again we do the split leader
look up for for our read because that's
the first thing that we send now we send
the read request to the split leader of
the zone a split 0 that is where my key
value 100 lives and the leaders and the
leader acquires a read lock read locks
again can be shared and sends the result
back now on my client I do something and
then I'm sending the rights so I'm
sending the write for 100 for 300 and
400 so before I send that of course I
have to do the lookup where the leaders
for these values live then I sent the
commit request to my split leader of the
sown a 100 split 0 which is my key 100
split leader and I send it through so in
C split
which is my key 300 sone and split
leader and then soo soon be and split
three which is my sone leader for the
key 400 now what the front end is doing
as well is when we do this right-hand
section is it is choosing a leader of
this of this multi split transaction we
need basically a leader who is in
control of this transaction now since it
is multi split we actually have to do
two-phase commit all right in the single
ride we didn't have to do full two-phase
commit but since this is multi split we
actually have to coordinate between the
different taxes groups so we have to do
with two-phase commit so when we then to
commit request each of the split leaders
is requesting the locks so I basically
do the right lock for the for the zone
bi right lock for a key 300 and I do
also verify the read lock for the first
one that I did I'm also writing this key
so I'm also requiring a requesting right
lock for that and then once all these
relax our required
I sent basically that back to the chosen
leader or coordinator of this
transaction so now what is happening
once I have all these confirmation that
my locks are required and they are still
valid the leader basically assigns tomb
timestamp to that transaction records
the commit to some replicas and once it
gets a maturity maturity of this in in
in their practice group it sends it out
to the other split leaders and then the
other split leaders is recording that
commit to the replicas in that in their
practice group and as soon as they have
the majorities they attend back base as
they basically are prepared for that
commit and then once the once this is
done basically we know that the commit
is done we have before the first phase
was basically verifying that we have all
the locks and that we can get all the
legs
the second phase here you see is
basically yes please commit that
transaction we have all the locks so we
can commit this transaction we again
made out the true time uncertainty and
report back the
the committe success to all our other
participants of that transaction and
then like in parallel pretty much the
mutation is applied now if there's any
like point in time where we have a lot
conflict for instance I acquire read log
and another transaction has a read lock
as well and then I want to upgrade that
read log to a write lock but since the
other transaction has a read lock I
cannot upgrade it to the write lock what
is happening in spanner is basically we
do a wait and wound so basically what is
this doing it is going to cancel a board
basically the transaction that is
younger so the front that knows the
ordering of the transaction and if they
see like there's a looming deadlock we
are basically aborting the younger
transaction let's sexy like let to push
proceed the older transaction and then
we just retry the younger transaction
that we aborted all right so with that
knowledge like what are the things to
look out for when working with loud
spanner
so first the foremost and that's like
one of the most like straightforward
ones sometimes still missed is the
choosing of the right primary keys
so primary keys I mentioned in the
beginning the tables are ordered
lexicographically or for the mirror
models iPhone numerically so if you have
something which is not monotonic
increasing or decreasing you basically
add to the let's last split order the
first split and as mentioned one split
is always owned by one computer source
so if you always add to one split you
basically exhaust the computer sources
on that split so the recommendation use
well distributed primary keys or
composite primary keys if if you can
also look at reordering your table if
you see that like that can help in
getting your key more disabuse you
comparing grammar key more distributed
another thing is be careful with
interleaving so interleaving can be
powerful interleaving is a technique
where you basically make sure that the
data lives on the same split
as a parent table so you interleave it
in the parent table they have to share
the same primary key in the beginning
for the shape same primary key prefix
and then it is interleaved and stored on
the same split as your parent role now
the danger is if you have one parent
role and a lot of data which relates to
that parent role you basically again end
up all with all the traffic to that data
to that child table in one split which
also leads to hot spotting so be careful
with that it is a technique to speed up
certain queries especially if you need
to do like some kinds of fast look ups
for certain data that where you want to
benefit from data locality you can use
in the living but be careful of it same
applies to indexes so indexes are just
tables in spanner so if you index a
monotonic field you get in the same
problem you get also into a hot spotting
so be careful there use like a lot of
application level charting key prefix or
something that is natural in your table
that you can use to prefix your indexes
now for complex transaction so one of
the things is spanner basically locks on
cell level so if you have like columns
and rows like the log level for for
spanner is on a cell level but if you do
for instance a read white one section
where you select on a non-key column
then your entire table for that column
is locked because we don't know like
what is the range like how many actually
it could be we also look for Nuka 4 new
rows inserted or for any rows that are
updated which could be qualifying for
that filter to set on a non key key
column so we basically locking the
entire column and with this you could
run into basically contention for your
rights so if we careful with this a good
strategy to do this is if you can use a
primary key in your filter so that you
basically can filter down on the primary
key which allows that we don't do a full
column table lock and the other thing is
if you can
do lookups or so like filtering before
you do actually the retry transaction so
a good technique is basically doing a
read-only transaction before your
read/write transaction get basically the
data that you really want to modify get
the primary keys of that and then use
that and verify that the data hasn't
hasn't changed in your read white
transaction and then we have a lot much
smaller scope of your transaction by
that you avoid a lot of the write
contention so to that point use read Y
transactions only if needed so read-only
transactions are actually lock less so
read-only transaction just use the true
time x them and we don't do any relaxed
we don't do a read lock or anything the
only time you do you actually acquire
read lock is inside a read Y transaction
if you do a read otherwise you don't
require any locks in your careers all
transactions now another thing that we
see in terms of like read contention
where you have a lot of they're they're
like like hot spotting basically Turing
reads one of the things is if you have
popular items it could be for instance
counter for a counter we recommend to
charge the counter if you need one it
could be a popular item let's say you
have like a social graph in your in your
Spano database and you have like that
star that everybody looks up and wants
to get the latest and latest news so to
avoid these kinds of hot data points one
technique that you can do is replicating
Turing rights
so you basically when you write you do
or we replicate replicas and then you
enable the read from these replicas
these rights are transactional so you
don't like you don't get the
inconsistency in there or if you can
look at your schema if you can do things
like reordering columns to avoid these
hot data spots another thing indexes
consider how you define your index is
also the same is for primary keys
spanner always scans from the top of the
table okay so if you have
like your index ordered ascending and
you asked for that index for let's say
you have like an index on updated and
like some charting epital up level
charting to to avoid hot spotting and
you want to have the latest updates on
certain kinds of data and you have your
index defined ascending these index that
doesn't help you to find your index
descending so that the newest values are
at the top and you don't need to scan
the entire index
another important thing since flowered
spanner is a distributed database we
don't have optimizations that you find
in single machine databases so if you
look at indexes in a single machine
relational database the way that indexes
are implemented if they are implemented
performant ly is that they are actually
pointing directly to the data point on
your disk or in memory where that data
lives now on span of that is not
possible because the data could live on
a different note like the index that you
have might be in a different split than
the data actually that you're accessing
with your query so the only thing that
we can do here is we do actually have to
do a back join to your to your parent
table now to avoid this what you can do
in your index definition is using
something like storing clause
so the storing Clause are your columns
that are not index but that you
basically attach to your index that or
will be carried around with your index
and might avoid a back draw into your
parent table now again like the things
that we also discussed during the write
contention apply also to read contention
consider reordering columns for better
distribution introduced app level
charting to basically avoid to avoid hot
spots and then the other thing is also
always to keep in mind choose use
indexes wisely so indexes are coming
with an improved read performance but at
the cost of reduce right because they
are spending multiple splits so pretty
much if you have an index defined unless
it's an interleaved index you always
will have a two-phase commit
during your rights
because you have other splits involved
that needs to be updated okay
so true same shoe same wisely not always
the indexes help okay and they also come
at the storage overhead so this is also
something to consider now if you look at
schema design and life cycles so one of
the things that we see especially if you
look at like continuous integration and
delivery setup one thing that is like
done like quite often actually Skelly
often is to do like schema changes with
like an continuous the delivery like and
like if you deploy like multiple times
maybe even during development especially
I if you deploy multiple times per
minute for instance you get all these
schema changes up for minutes
and now what happens is actually spanner
is built in a way cloudspinners built in
a way to to serve live traffic while
schema changes are ongoing so our our
biggest primer is like concern is we
want to serve live traffic while we also
allow allow online schema changes so we
basically take a hit we accept the hit
on on the schema changes to be
propagated
but for that you get the life life
serving of your traffic now there's also
another thing basically these schema
changes are done sequentially there are
preparation phases which are done in
parallel while your let traffic is going
on and then if we at the point that we
do the switch over we choose basically
to time times them they are
transactional we choose the true time
times them at the point that we switch
over the schema we are boring all the
transactions that are in flight at that
point that would conflict which
basically would spend two versions of
the schema now another point to consider
is we are keeping schema changes in
memory for about an hour a little longer
the reason that we are doing this is we
allowing time bounded reads and a time
bound reads you can basically go back in
time and by going back in time you could
actually hit ascii an old schema so we
still need to be able to serve the
traffic for that old scheme
for time boundaries so keep that in mind
it is basically encourage memory
pressure on our notes because it's
taking up space if you do extrema change
and so we are basically kind of lowering
the amount of schema changes that you
can can do per time unit so really
consider that when you're doing schema
update is that you don't do them too
often like in a short amount of time
also one thing to to mention is if you
create indexes for instance in your in
your schema changes there of course like
s in other databases they need to be
backfilled
especially in in spanner beakers they
are like just normal table we basically
need to pay for these these indexes
depending on the amount of data that you
have that can take minutes hours or
sometimes even days if you have like a
lot of indexes that you need to backfill
all right a couple of things in the
application design we introduced
recently the commit time stem so you can
now add a column to your schema that
automatically that you can sale in your
client please fill that column with the
commit times them you can use that for
instance if you update any data like to
this be automatically filled I've put it
down in Java and go we have that for
many many other languages as well you
see there you basically define like a
like a constant that you provide in your
right hand section and it will be
automatically filled on the back end
with the value of the times then one
important thing is also to benefit from
caching from query caching and to avoid
of course SQL injection attacks use
please use bounded parameters that these
allow you to basically don't allow us to
do more efficient caching and by that
basically lowering also response times
because we don't need to create a new
query plan every time right in terms of
like both data imports and exports so
one on the one hand we have a patchy
beam connector
which is doing all the hard work for you
to do optimizing the export and import
of data we also have it just recently
last week I believe announced that we
have import and export built into cloud
console so what you can do now is you
just like a button you say yo Google
Cloud storage destination and say like I
want to export there and then you can
basically import from there as well
very long-awaited feature from many from
our customers so we're really happy that
this is now available and it will
actually improve over time as well now
if you're somebody like me who wants to
actually understand and do all the bulk
loading and importing and exporting
yourself there is a trick to get the
maximum throughput for your important
and exports especially for the imports
to avoid the right contention I have a
video series around that too please feel
free to follow up on that but basically
what you do is you load a large amount
of rows in into cache you sort these
rows by your primary key that can be a
composite 8 key you basically sort that
by then then you split them into chunks
into distinct ranges of of your primary
key chunks and then you send those
chunks in parallel now somebody might
say like wait didn't you say like not
monotonic increasing in these decreasing
primary key why are you sorting the
reason here is you're sorting and
sending in parallel all these chunks
which basically means they go to
different splits there might be some
overlap but spanner will recognize that
during time we do load balanced
optimizations load balanced splitting
load balanced handover of
responsibilities for for splits during
your traffic so we can actually optimize
that and since you send a bunch or many
many of these sorted ranges through
spanner we can actually get a really
high throughput so I was able to get
like I think 12 12 X speed up by just
using that technique of importing data
another thing which we recently added is
tracing
which is integrated directly into
stackdriver and i going to demonstrate
that in a little bit so basically that
allows to you to get some insights into
where is your very low is it actually
spanner that is like taking a lot of
time is it maybe on your client side
which uses a lot of time and you can
actually optimize on the client side so
open sensors allows you to do some
tracing there and we actually if you get
these IDs for this for your traces they
go back into our system so we actually
can trace certain queries that you have
found that all slow on our side we can
actually use your the UID and trace them
back in our systems and see what what
was going on so that is actually pretty
powerful I encourage everybody to check
it out and use it and I'm gonna show it
in a little bit all right so let me
actually show that at the first time so
I'm going to switch over to my demo
laptop so basically how are you setting
up tracing in spanner I hope it's that
visible or should I make that a little
bigger let me get that away alright so
basically to get opened open senses
tracing you this isn't go apologize for
ever and for anybody who is not a go
person but currently my favorite
language so here in stack driver you
basically define a new exporter with
some stack driver options so in this
case the project ID and some attributes
that you define I basically attach some
labels to my traces I want to have the
demo that I that is running and the
region where this is running in this
client and then I send set up some views
and register that exporter so there
basically is all the setup here last but
not least we apply a config for this
trace and say like okay how many traces
do I want to get from all my requests so
you see here like I want to have 1% of
my requests as traced and then these are
sent to two stackdriver
now how does it look like if I do my
actual
query so in my extra query let's say I'm
doing right for a sequential row so I do
a sequential right here so I define a
span by starting that span which is
basically the containment of my trace
for for for round 12 let's say it's that
way I'm ending that span and when the
function is left and then I'm using that
context that I'm using here and passing
that context basically down in my
library so this is really important if
you use go that you use the same context
and basically just wrap the context if
you need some other qualities so here
for instance I'm doing context with a
timeout where I say like if after five
second doesn't come back please cancel
that that whole thing so I'm wrapping
basically the context that I'm getting
in my function into the into this
timeout context and then at the end like
that's pretty much it I don't have to do
anything else like all the open sensors
tracing is already supported in the
library it's literally these two these
two rows up here which enable the
tracing now how does that look like in
my Explorer so we can see here for
instance all the traces that I have
collected let's update this and see if
this is still running so we see okay
this is the running it shows you
basically what are the times here for
these traces now you see that our they
are pretty much like three lines kind of
in response time and the reason for this
is actually the most upper line is
clients running in Asia against a cloud
spanner instance in the US the middle
line is my client's running in Europe
against my large spanner instance in the
US and the most the lowest one here
which has like very low round-trip times
is my clients running in the US in the
same region as my cloud spanner instance
now the great thing that you can do here
is you can pick one of those
and show events and it shows you
basically okay I'm acquiring a read-only
session and acquired a read-only session
and then I'm going to spanner and do the
commit and you see the 200 milliseconds
here now let's see if I can maybe find
something else so here you see for
instance you're iterating between a
sequential right you see the things that
are going on if I'm going a little bit
further down let's see if I can find one
yesterday I found a really nice one
which showed me that for instance if
your session pool is too small and it's
night it needs to require a session then
you see basically it's like okay I'm
waiting for a session I'm waiting for a
session I'm waiting for the session oh
now I cut the Sabbath session so the
entire query or took like is let's say
500 milliseconds but the actual spanner
part of it was 5 milliseconds the 495
milliseconds force the client trying to
acquire a session and you can fix these
things on your client side so you can
basically get insights into where where
is the problem
or my query slow or it's actually my
client not optimized for for the things
that I'm doing with it all right so the
next thing that I want to talk about is
multi-region configurations so we have
two offers right now we have a multi
region continental and we have a multi
region global both of them give you a
five nines as a so you the the regional
instance gives you a four nine SLA the
Altai region gives you a five nine SaaS
now what is continental Matt original
instance you get a full copy of the
database in two regions you have the
paksas that I explained earlier across
three regions I'm gonna go a little bit
in more detail in a second and it is
available even if one of your regions or
read wide regions becomes unavailable so
the same applies for the multi region
global whereas for the module region
global you add to read-only copies of
your food read-only copies on to more
continents in this case Europe
and Asia now how does it look like for
multi-region continental you basically
have a region one I have a region two
and then you have a so-called witness
region now the witness region has a lock
store but it doesn't have a copy of your
data and the witness region is basically
somebody who has voting rights but
cannot serve data now why do we need
this witness region we need it actually
for the high availability now let's
assume like your region 2 becomes
unavailable right if you only would have
these two regions in your quarrel you
cannot really get a quorum so you could
have like a split brain you don't want
that so you need some kind of like a
third region to get the majority and in
your row in your wordings for the packs
escrow and the witness region has this
function for you so now if region two
for instance goes down we can still
serve data from region 1 because the
witness region helps to have the quorum
for the transactions now on the global
setup
you basically have region 1 red white
you have another region read white in in
the yes in this case now for quorums
again you also have a witness region
depending how far they are away from
each other
you basically in cured around two times
four for your transactions especially in
the in the two-phase commit and then you
have the read-only regions which are on
the right side and the you in Europe and
in Asia now what do the read-only
regions bring you they bring basically
first they are there to serve data so
not always you have to ship data
basically from your read white regions
second if you use stale time bounded
consistent reads these can be served
directly from your read-only regions if
we have the latest data there so if you
use like 10 seconds you're pretty much
safe to use that so in the test in the
in the case of rights and consistent
reads so you see the blue lines on the
right is a strong read now if we care
basically in from client Asia goes into
the read-only copy in Asia and asked
like hey I want to have the data so what
we encourage this round trip
time to the readwrite region and asked
like hey do we have the latest data then
we get the response and reserve the data
from Asia now if you have a right we
don't go through the read-only region we
go directly to the readwrite region so
to where the splits lives in there in
the red white regions now if you US
client comes in it's pretty much the
same as you have four regional now if
you have time bounded once again you
basically go to to your read-only region
if it is within the the bound that you
have that data already you can just
serve it without even consulting your
really wide region okay so before I go
in and the related session I just want
to show my last couple of minutes a
couple of things so one that I want to
do is I want to start a demo so what I
built here I just want to explain it a
little bit so if you go to the showcase
in Moscone West and you go to the
cloudspinners showcase we have one that
basically illustrates the manageability
of cloud spanner and then there's a
station to where you can play with
scaling the number of nodes out and in
and scaling the throughput up and down
and it shows you how quickly spanner
actually adapts to changing through
ports as well as how quickly nodes that
you add become available to serve your
your workload it's pretty amazing so
I've built this app or basically the
back end by having clients running in
kubernetes and they are attaching to a
pops up session and then I can use pops
up to send a message and instruct them
how much traffic to serve how much
traffic to send against loud spinner so
how much we traffic how much ride
traffic how much time bounded with
traffic now I found that very powerful
because it is in very easy way to have
an interface to communicate with
especially like the agency that both the
station and the backend that I was
building so in this case what I want to
show here is I I've set up a system
where I want to show you the differences
between a multi regional continental and
a multi-regional global instance in
terms of
like kind of what the latencies are that
you're gonna see so let's have a look
here I'm gonna change - let's say
multi-region global I can save these
changes okay you can accrue oh thank you
very much
apologize for that okay so basically
what you see here in the upper graph is
it's showing on this right so the yellow
line is random reads coming from the US
the no the the yellow is Asia random
reads from Asia the blue ones are the
second line from the top is Europe and
the lowest one is us so as you can see
like the es random reads for global
instance is nine milliseconds these are
point reads and for Asia it's 165 and
for Europe it's 114 so these are strong
reads okay now if we look at time
bounded once we see here all of them are
below 10 milliseconds so this is the
power of time bounded reads these time
variant reads have like a staleness
up to 10 milliseconds 10 seconds
apologies they ever stay on this up to
10 seconds but all of them are served
within 10 10 milliseconds so that is the
power especially if you want to really
like filter your data you can can use it
very nicely now if we look at the multi
region continental what you see there is
pretty much very similar times but now
as you can see the random reads are 185
milliseconds so we had before like a
hundred forty milliseconds so the reason
for that is the data has always to be
shipped to my clients in Asia because
they don't have a read-only copy so this
is like just even for this point point
reads it makes like a forty milliseconds
roughly difference by having this
read-only copy in in in Asia and in the
local region now I want to show one more
thing if it is working let's see yeah so
here I'm displaying basically again
random random writes so we have here
writes from the US
about 30 30 milliseconds this is going
to regionals instance from Asia around
200 milliseconds and from your about 130
milliseconds around to time the
sequential writes right now it has
started it's about the same now if I
would put that up it takes a little bit
time you basically would see that
spanner tops out at like 35% of usage in
in your instance because I'm basically
always hitting the last bit so the the
throughput that I would get for the
quencher writes is much lower even
though I have the same amount of
computer resources available all right
so last but not least related sessions
there is a session right now which you
have missed so thank you for coming here
instead of that session which is about
replacing Oracle cloud spanner you can
watch it on beyond YouTube we will
recording all these sessions I mean
putting them up on YouTube so you might
not have missed it out completely
because it you can basically go back and
watch it the 2x2 Moroso session about
microwaving cloud spanner which is
talking about migrating from an SQL
database in that case I think my my scar
that they are talking about
we have also another session in this
afternoon where bandai namco a games
company a japanese campaigns company
built from the ground up on cloud
spanner a game really interesting I
worked with them last year at next Tokyo
I really recommend going there and then
tomorrow is also like what's new about
cloud spanner from the PM dipti who is
talking about basically roadmap features
and last but not least a little bit
advertising about myself please if you
are interested in like ongoing topics
around cloud spanner
I have a video series on YouTube which
is called PIL about cloud spanner so you
see that here which basically means
things I learned about loud spanner or
today I learned about loud spanner you
pick your favorite you can scan the QR
code you can also follow me on twitter
under at hasta raza t I'm mostly
tweeting about tech knowledge
she very early about like personal
things and with that thank you thank you
very much for attending my talk
[Applause]
[Music]